after don't look like July
just
the Pioneer plaques these are identical
gold-plated plaques attached to the
pioneer 10 and 11 spacecraft they each
have a picture of the solar system a
picture of the spacecraft itself and of
course a pictorial representation of the
hyperfine transition of neutral hydrogen
ring a bell no well they also have
pictures of a naked man and woman ah yes
now you remember at the time a lot of
people objected to that image saying it
was nothing more than interstellar porn
other people had a problem with the fact
that it was the man who is raising his
hand in greeting presumably leaving the
woman's hands-free to make a nice batch
of muffins for the aliens personally my
objection is the humans are depicted
completely without body hair aliens are
going to come down look at us and think
we're living in symbiosis with our pubes
see the Voyager record i love that we
sent an LP into space it's so
delightfully retro aliens are going to
find this and say truly this is an
artifact of an extremely groovy
civilization should we contact them we
don't know what to expect but we should
prepare ourselves for a very very mellow
time in actuality the most funky track
on the album is Johnny be good which I
don't think is a great choice I mean I
don't know how you carry a guitar in a
gunnysack and i was born on this planet
be the era SIBO message this is actually
a short binary image projected into
space when properly decoded it creates a
black and white pixelated image that
looks remarkably similar to an old Atari
2600 video game from looking at it it
looks like you're supposed to maneuver
your guy through the caverns up the
waterfall get past the attacking aliens
and grab a delicious piece of cake all
while avoiding the evil letter M I'd
play that game it should be noted here
that the guy on this image is also naked
but it's ok because he's pixelated we
don't want aliens to know that we have
genitals but it's ok if they mistake us
for a table lamp
a the teenage message this message was
beamed into space in 2001 it starts with
some radio transmission Doppler tuning
boring boring boring thing moves into a
bunch of theremin music theremin music
and finally ends with another image
including the teenage message logo so
lame it's called the teenage message
because it was put together by a group
of Russian teenagers I think that's
going to be immediately apparent to
anyone who picks up the message jours
block what is this tedious boring
message we have received well Jerry I
don't know but it sounds as if it was
put together by Russian teenagers d
television signals a Condon science
fiction trouble involves aliens
intercepting our television signals and
using them as the basis for their entire
civilization that doesn't seem very
likely I mean we get all sorts of
television shows and we don't base our
entire life around a long-defunct series
well except for firefly fans it's also
pretty egotistical I mean if an alien
race can get our television signals then
they can get any television signal in
the galaxy and I hear Cygnus has some
pretty awesome public access shows
nonetheless if this is what's going to
happen I say we take advantage of it and
start broadcasting nothing but shows
about benevolent aliens who come down to
earth and give human beings candy at
hugs and play super smash brothers with
them but don't take pit because he's
cheap c-minus
you